[Music]
animal segments can be tricky that's one
thing that and especially if you have
any phobias about certain animals and it
just comes with this job like before I
got a talk show I never went near any of
these animals suddenly have a talk show
every couple of weeks you have to handle
animals and you had a certain problem
with a I don't know folk about snakes I
know and that's what animals period
right I mean I don't a dog I had dogs
right had cats too but other than that I
don't mess with animals they always said
like one-in-a-million chance well I'm
not one that's the way I look at it so
we always have alligators and coyotes
and and all these crazy animals but
snakes especially I just can't deal with
it I don't like it thanks man I don't do
well with snakes and I guess someone
played a bit of a child and a guest on
who knew that you didn't like snakes
that hayden Panettiere girl yeah
[Applause]
say that sounds like she's a neighbor
yeah yeah it can't he pee in his house
here it's like you're describing it to
the cops
there was inner being one of most
embarrassing things that ever happened
to me on the show but it should he'll
believe me a macho football player and
she brought on a tiny rubber no so we
were talking she was saying she got some
new finger snakes that's what they call
him a little miniature snakes and she
had some pictures and I'm looking at the
screen of the pictures of her with her
snakes and then I'm turning she said I
brought them with me
right and I turn and look and she throws
these sake sake and they're lucky I just
didn't flat-out curse on morning TV I'm
sure your pleasure yeah we have that
moment let's take a look at it right now
[Music]
[Applause]
that is absolutely perfect why did y'all
slow it down cuz it's more excruciating
I had no idea man that that that my
heart still drops every time I see that
and then they want to air it in the
taxis I just want to get I just want to
go across town I don't need to see
myself get scared yeah and their hotness
yeah it's just everything it's just yeah
you you want that just to go away yeah
yet people keep showing it and showing
it
[Music]
[Applause]
you can hit me if you want you know just
to show you I have we've had plenty of
animal segments on this show and I had a
different problem with we we had a
lizard on the show that that and and the
unexpected happens
and I think we have a clip of that it's
a globe okay so you can see the fuzz
[Applause]
would you rather have worse in that
situation well I mean looks like you
kind of lean to the left to my opinion
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you want a much better situation to be
at least if it maintains of dignity man
the way I did talking about all the
dudes who used to be afraid of me well I
call we whip your butt now Michael we
saw that snake thing yeah if I walk
around on lizard dicks that's what I
you